to grocery stores where at least five
employees at supermarket chains all
across the country have died from the
virus including two at the same Chicago
area Walmart Walmart says it is quote
heartbroken by those deaths and it now
faces a wrongful death lawsuit from the
family of one of those workers our
Adriana Diaz spoke to the sister of the
other worker who died everybody Waldman
I loved him he loved them when Angela
McMiller called to check on her brother
Phillip Thomas at the hospital a nurse
came to the phone instead he said well
we did everything we could
and I said wait a minute are you telling
me my brother passed away 48 year-old
Thomas who'd worked for Walmart for nine
years died two days after calling an
ambulance for himself after struggling
to stand up do you know if your brother
was wearing a mask and gloves at work I
don't think they were worried
none of them were wearing that mask
those four employees trying to keep up
with customer demands there's no break
[Music]
Tuesday grocery store workers in Boston
demanded masks and gloves fully paid
sick leave and hazard pay some stores
have installed floor markers and
plexiglass including Walmart the company
is also now limiting customers and
stores providing masks and gloves for
employees who want them and taking their
temperatures upon arrival these measures
should have been taken from day one but
that's not stopping attorney Tony
Kellogg Arrakis from suing Walmart on
behalf of Wando Evans who worked at the
same stores Phillip Thomas and died from
the virus the same week the wrongful
death suit claims the store failed to
notify employees that others had
symptoms of the virus I am concerned
because I'm a Walmart consumer I love
Walmart so to think that I have to risk
my life when I walked through the door
is scary
Walmart responded to the wrongful death
suits hit saying it's taking the issue
seriously and will respond in court once
it receives a complaint now it's not
known if the employees contracted the
virus while working here at this store
but of course any essential employees
faced increased exposure just by leaving
their homes and being around others
Anthony Adriana thank you